[Music]
this factory in germany has made engines
for some of the most popular cars in the
world for over five decades
ever wish you owned a volkswagen but
more recently
some of those cars have lost their shine
vw owners coming to grips with the
realization that their diesel cars can
emit from 10
to 40 times more pollutants we all know
that
we have let down customers what's more
global sales of internal combustion
engines are predicted to drop by over 50
by 2035. the hot new market electric
vehicles
so to try and capture that market vw is
transforming this engine factory
into its new ev battery facility the
first of six that it plans to build in
europe
at a cost of about 15 billion dollars
according to analysts
what you see behind has nothing to do
with combustion engines and that shows
the size of this transformation that
means going from making combustion
engines that have more than 2
000 moving parts to high-tech electric
motors that only have about 20
and changing its workforce to do that
traditional automakers
if they want to be in this market in
2035 they need to develop just as much
as the startups need to develop the ev
market is currently dominated by tesla
and faces disruption from a bunch of new
startups they have nothing to lose they
start from scratch
we have a lot to lose so could this
factory be a blueprint for traditional
automakers to survive the ev revolution
[Music]
while vw says that its battery factory
and salt skitter
won't be online for another two years or
so tesla already has
several gigafactories in operation and
completed its shanghai facility
in under a year it also says it's
nearing completion of a huge plant here
in germany
we've decided to put tesla gigafactory
europe
uh in the berlin area other well-funded
startups like lucid and rivien have set
up brand new factories to start ev
production this year
so legacy automakers like gm ford and vw
have all announced they're investing
billions into ev production to defend
their market share
with vw committing to 43 billion dollars
in five years
when you look at what the startups are
doing they don't have to transition you
don't have to change a legacy
a legacy footprints so traditional
automakers don't have
the luxury of sitting back and saying ah
we'll wait and see how it goes
we are responsible for the people and
for our customers
and we have to transform so how is vw
investing that money in saltskitter
well some of those decisions are made by
this engineer frank blohm
we are building a small-scale cells
right now and now we are building up the
first mass production plant
vw has converted part of its existing
factory into labs and a pilot line
to test and refine the science behind
its batteries it plans to build a brand
new facility right next to it which
could produce batteries for over 600 000
vehicles a year
and is expected to cost around 2.5
billion dollars according to analysts
although it says it hasn't finalized the
designs for its new facility yet
the factory is expected to be similar to
this one in sweden it's owned by battery
supplier north vault
and vw is a major investor in the
company
thomas schmoll is ceo of vw's component
division
the bottleneck will be how fast you can
establish
increase and ramp up your battery
business within its labs vw is trying to
figure out what kind of batteries its
electric
vehicles will need in the future it's
testing battery recycling technology
and to get ahead of the competition it's
experimenting with next generation
solid state batteries which don't
contain liquid lithium
and promise far faster charging and
greater mileage fast charge is a big big
topic for us we are working on that
with with the big workforce the
transition will affect everyone in this
plant
the company will need fewer mechanical
engineers and will need new people with
totally different skills like
electrochemists or developers
as evs needs so much software that vw is
set to become one of the largest tech
companies in europe
to find the right people is a challenge
the new industry everybody wants
electrochemistry people
i think the big outstanding question is
we we know that it will take
fewer employees to build
a battery cell pack so therefore how do
you figure that out
where do you transition people to as the
battery plant grows over time
part of the staff will be retrained
while some legacy jobs are expected to
go away
at the end of this transition it's
unclear whether the overall number of
workers on this site will go down
globally vw has already made some cuts
in 2019 the company announced that it
was cutting some
7 000 jobs over 5 years and since 2016
it has eliminated at least 23 000
positions
by offering early retirement and not
replacing workers
we always have this this um issue oh
maybe it's destroying business no it's
not right you can if you do it right you
can
create jobs we will have 1 500 1 600
employees in uh in the new cell business
what we are doing here and that's not
um the end because this is only the
first portion the first part of the cell
plant
the stakes are particularly high for vw
as it's trying to change its image as a
polluter
while also meeting new environmental
regulations around the world
after the emissions scandal in 2015 vw
pleaded guilty to installing a device on
its vehicles to cheat us emissions tests
it is not only our cars we have to fix
we know we have to repair our
credibility
too today as vw bets big on electric
its u.s sales are much lower than they
were in 2012.
i think it does dovetail with with
needing to prove that they're clean and
and having that kind of hanging over
their heads
um because it does the news doesn't stop
it still still pop up so the issue isn't
completely dead
so just like this factory the
decades-old company has to reinvent
itself to keep up with technology
and beat competitors old and new